[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ecoutez jean s'est coupé c coupé au
pouvoir sur une île est dément t'as vu
ça c'est à la hauteur de dicaprio dans
un revenant
c'est que le lapin la basse et c'est un
vrai lapin
[Musique]
pour les 30 ans gars est ce qu on fait
quoi on ferait pas une grosse fête la
faune entendu pas dans ces eaux se
ferait du bien tout ça vous fait plaisir
de vous voir là comme ça toujours
ensemble réunit une grande fan ça fait
dix ans que j'ai toujours le meilleur
chiffre d'affaires de lagence ouais sauf
qu'un dujardin galles de cannes et ça
n'est pas de déplacer je connais ces
agences il ya urgence la bouche précise
tap à des copains me présente à lancy ge
lorsque je suis aussi heureux notre et
moniales l'eau qu'est ce que tu cherches
et le tour est joué mec normal
[Musique]
tu as marqué rien je te drogue mais non
verrouillées
lâche que des carottes sautées ya
l'homme de ma vie jésus l'allégorie du
buisson publie ce qui est compris
carrément vrai
je fais quoi je vous en parlais il
prendra cours de travaux
[Musique]
oui 10%
quand il a mis que de la mousson